[Music]
hello and welcome to the beyond the
series by the institute of art and ideas
my name is bernardo castrop and my name
is
fred motzer in this series
we are exploring four concepts that
underpin
and define the modern world knowledge
competition language and growth
and in each episode we're joined
by a leading thinker to help us and
hopefully you
see each concept in a new light this is
the fourth episode of the series
and today we are discussing growth the
concept has come to play a key role
in almost everything we consider
important and desirable
from business and economics to
psychology and happiness
but this concept has ancient roots that
differ
considerably from its modern
applications
here to discuss the concept of growth
with us
is former chief business officer for
google x
entrepreneur and the author of the book
so for happy
mo girl dot oh it's a great pleasure uh
to have you here thank you um we will be
discussing growth today which may come
as a surprise
or a slight surprise for the listeners
of beyond us
and the philosophy for our times because
it seems to be such a clear concept
right growth an increase in something
an increase in a quantity somewhere but
we suspect that there is more to it we
think that the concept of growth
goes deeper there are more subtleties
and nuances
and one of them may be that we hardly
think in terms of qualitative growth in
our society today
we think always in terms of quantitative
growth
we describe the world through quantities
in physics
economics which is driven by
quantitative growth and
dictates largely how our society works
so what is your take on that do you do
you think
maybe we are over emphasizing
quantitative growth
at the cost of qualitative growth which
may be deeper and more important
what an amazing question and topic to
cover i i'm grateful that you
uh you know would want to listen to my
view on this i think we're over
emphasizing
growth to stop where to start with
before we even talk about quantitative
versus qualitative i think the reality
is that
um we've built a society in a capitalist
environment that is all about
more more more more more and more
seems to be what we we sort of
measure life by now when in reality
there are
many things in our lives uh where
growth is not that great when you really
think about it
uh you know about your early years in
life when you were a child and happy and
having the best time of your life
uh you know and then you grow and you
know the more you grow the grumpier you
become
and the less you know uh free you become
and the less
the more out of flow you become you know
you're a young person and you're fully
in touch with your
feminine side and masculine side and
you're engaging in life and then they
put you in the work environment and you
grow what do you grow
into more and more of a masculine
creature that is all about doing all
about achieving all about analytics and
so on and so forth
you know we continue to grow further for
a very long time and then eventually we
end up what
aging you know being frail and dying
growth
is not always an interesting target to
have i
i believe that um that truly
finding your true self should be the
target to have now
add to this of course your point of view
where we
start to identify everything by
again a capitalist ideal
of it needs to be a title it needs to be
possessions
it needs to be you know comparison
between me and others around me
when in reality uh you know
you could grow uh in terms of the
people you benefited in your life today
you could grow in terms of the
love you've given to others today you
could grow in terms of
your understanding of yourself today
and none of that is actually measured as
a as a qualifier of growth when you
think about it
i spent maybe 25 years of my life
in corporate america have done really
really well
uh you know in my last job as the chief
business officer of google x i've
achieved quite a lot
in the previous job before that i've you
know expanded google to four billion
more users and
you know made a lot of money and then
you know in my personal story when my
son left our world and i assigned myself
the
the the target of one billion happy
you know the mission statement openly
between us as a team and one billion
happy is
if by the end of my life i've spent
every dollar i've ever earned on making
a billion people happy
and we've achieved that amazing target
and then
uh you know we became completely
forgotten we've managed to
you know galvanize a million champions
to champion a billion happy and we
became completely forgotten
isn't that an amazing life isn't that
true growth
you know not just for me but for the
world around me
thank you bo um yeah i think
it is very very heavy on
anybody to lose a child
i lost my brother brother
when he was 21 related to suicide still
not known
why but here also is growth
and when i ponder about growth i see
on one side around us we see
nature we as humans are one of the
billions of expressions of life but are
so many other expressions that grow
decay and die
as we do and then indeed we see as
bernardo put the question right we
associate growth
basically we hijack the word growth
while we mean to
increase and we try to increase
stuff that we take away from nature
and don't see the effects of that taking
away and make it
in combinations that we like and we use
so how do you compare
the natural world to a human
attitude that abuses
the growth and instead takes in greece
for growth
yeah i i that's such an interesting view
of it because
what are we growing we're growing um
the number of cars we have in our garage
the number of recreational trips we have
the number of
devices that we use and so on and so
forth we're
growing our life of luxury as
opposed to what are we losing what's the
price that we're paying for all of this
and the price is very straightforward
the prices were losing the planet
right and you know and and it's it's
quite interesting because
if we told everyone uh by the way
for every uh gallon of um
of of fuel that you use we're gonna tax
you
a day of your life at the end uh people
will start to think
oh interesting so if i was supposed to
live 70 years and i
used 365 gallons uh i
i will you know live 69 years only
that's an interesting thing to think
about
and and and the truth here is that we're
taxing our entire life we're taxing our
entire planet
less and less years you know to live
we're just literally telling everyone
for you to have the convenience of
commuting to work alone
and have the luxury of flying over to
the maldives and burning
tons of fuel because your beach
that is you know at 10 kilometers or 100
kilometers away is not good enough
yeah i think it's because nobody is
really thinking about what are we
growing
and what are we um um uh losing
uh you know in in in result as a result
of that
it's it's tim it's simply like telling a
bodybuilder
you know go to the uh to to the gym and
grow your muscles massively by using
steroids or whatever but understand that
three years from now or seven years from
now you're going to be fat and rounded
and you're not going to be able to keep
it going
right and it's it's interesting because
yes we want to grow but
shouldn't we grow um what
actually matters i mean on my podcast on
slo-mo i hosted
the um the uh host of a
of a very famous netflix documentary
called connected
and basically the whole documentary
speaks about
how every one of us and every part of
life is connected right when you know it
it basically speaks about how you
changing
something in you know as a sahara in
africa would
end up affecting the amazon uh forest
and
in the in the process in the middle kill
a few sharks and
you know take a couple of ships on track
and so on and so forth
and i think the challenge with humanity
is that we don't see it that way
we we see it as hey i want to drive
another thousand kilometers
and and i i think what we're doing is
we're shrinking we're not growing we're
literally killing our planet when i was
a
kid in the late 70s and early 80s
more in the beginning of the computer
and automation revolution
um there was a lot of talk in the media
about
you know automation reducing our
workload
that is more this more you know
laborious tasks would be performed by
computers and machines and robots
and we would have a lot more time for
ourselves
which would be great for growth because
we would have time to
grow then as people
but because of this mad rush for
increase as fred put it not growth mad
rush for increase which we call growth
we still work more than we worked back
then
probably because we are in this
desperate mad
dash to keep growing i mean in the
corporate world i was in the corporate
world for over
well over 20 years and there is this
adage that a company that doesn't grow
is a dead company
so now we've equated increase with
existence
so if if we don't increase we no longer
exist
um isn't that a fantastic missed
opportunity for true
growth if we would stop this mad dash
and then focus on
actual growth as nature does i
i i i think it's it's mad in so many
ways because
uh from one side we have had a
definition of growth
that's actually not at all related to
growth right so if
if you ask me i mean i i post that a lot
on social media and i
speak to a lot of you know varied people
on my podcast but i actually do
speak to quite a few monks right
and um you know i i'm fascinated by the
impact that meditation would have on
your health and life and so on
and so i interviewed matthew ricard and
john brown
and so on uh sorry gail
gailin topton and top ten gin plan and
so on and they tell you
that their life is a life
of growth and i'm like hold on i mean
matthew rickard
is a phd in cell biology
right uh who gives up on all of that
and um you know goes through a life of
45 years of meditation and
self-reflection and teaching and so on
and i asked him and i said matthew you
know you've given up on a wife on a
family on a phd on a life and
and he says well um but i've gained
myself
and and when you when you think about it
i i was like
what do you mean huh what what have you
uh
gained and he said well you know i
actually
am happy i feel centered i feel
i feel balanced i'm not hungry okay i
don't
crave anything and you know not have it
uh
not because i have everything but
because i don't crave most of the things
that people crave
right and and you know it's a it's a
very long story having said that i will
be very open and honest
humanity in the last you know 100 years
has created an incredible civilization i
mean when you really think about it just
take something like
average age and mortality rates
we've grown the average age of humans
from 40 some year
years you know just 100 years ago or
less to more than 70 years
in some countries 80 years as an average
78 years as an average that's not a bad
thing
that's not something we can complain
about and say huh but you know working
too hard for that is that is a bad price
to pay that's a great thing that
civilization contributed
so so there is a benefit to having
uh you know advancement and progress the
question really is
how much of it is enough and what's the
price we pay for it how much is enough
is a very very interesting question
do we need an iphone 13
and if the if the if the price of the
iphone server 13
is going to be horrendous impact on the
planet and your stress level and your
life and so on
maybe then we don't and
and that's an interesting question so um
you know
[Music]
um
i worked i worked many years in my life
in technology and then i eventually
decided to leave technology and focus on
one billion happy
but but my next book is actually on a
very different topic my next book coming
out hopefully in a few months is called
scary smart it's about artificial
intelligence
right and if you and i you know i don't
want to scare anyone i actually have a
very optimistic outlook on
on everything if we do uh if we do it
right but
i'll tell you openly huh if you see
the impact that technology the missed
promise as i call it
we promised people more time for their
family and loved ones we took away more
of their time
we promised them mobility we gave them
frantic
pressure we promised them utopia and we
gave them stress with technology
we promised them information and we gave
them a lack of privacy
we've used them as products to advertise
and all of that
now imagine that and give that to an
artificially intelligent machine and
start to question what's the price that
we're going to pay for that
and then you start to question why are
we doing it in the first place
and sadly in my book i say it's because
of something we call the three
inevitables it's going to happen anyway
and the question really is what are we
going to do about it but that
constant constant drive for more
if as it's as if a call center today is
not good enough
we need an automated call center that's
run by alexa
no it's not for my benefit don't lie to
me anymore this is not my benefit
this is the benefit of the company that
doesn't want to pay the call center
operator
okay don't sell it to me don't lie to me
the truth is
we don't need more we do want more in
terms of health research and maybe some
you know in income equalization whatever
there are many many problems in the
world
but a better call center no i apologize
you know another iphone
not really no that
uh i love the idea that your central
theme
is to make as many people happy as you
can
so that means basically that you want
growth
in happiness not even in number also but
in quality of happiness
seeing other so that's a quite something
on the natural side it's not only
seeing growing of something material but
a feeling within
because we cannot measure really happy i
cannot say i'm more happy than you
only that i can be more happy than
yesterday perhaps
so being a man of i.t
um how can we get what we have
built and basically so we have
taken away all other elements from
nature so that
the natural growth is limiting on that
side but having done so
how can we use those schools to bring
people back on our team
to make people more naturally happy
well well i think i think
yeah i think there is a misunderstanding
of happiness again because of the
capitalist world if you don't mind
me saying that we you can't sell
happiness because we're all born happy i
mean
look at a child you know if if they're
loved and
saved and fed and given their basic
needs for survival
uh they don't you know wonder why their
neighbor has an aston martin and they
don't
okay they don't you know ask for an xbox
to be happy they don't want anyone to
like their butt shot on
instagram to be happy and and i think
the idea is that
you know if if we were left to our
nature
and and the world allowed us to remove
the reasons for unhappiness
what's left behind is happy but you
can't sell that
you know aston martin cannot go and say
hey buy your
you know i'm not attacking a specific
company but you know luxury cars
companies cannot tell you
hey by the way happiness is innate
within you you can find it by
really really accepting life and doing
what you the best that you can
um you know that's not a very good sales
strategy and so
we're in that place where we're taught
to criticize everything so we see what's
wrong with everything we're taught to
to to want everything that we don't have
and never feel contented with what we
have
and because of that we're constantly
unhappy now happiness in my work
is very measurable it's very predictable
it's a simple equation happiness
is equal to or greater than the
difference between the events of your
life
and your expectations of how life should
be and i'll i'll give you the
the starkest of all examples i i started
2020 you know we all do new year's
new year's resolutions i did what i call
the new year's intention i i don't like
resolutions they sound too much like
targets from my boss
so my my new year's intention for 2020
was it's going to be my year of silence
and space and so they lock us down
whoa i'm like wow thank you i appreciate
it
it's like i appreciate the lockdown
right and of course as you look around
the world there are many many people who
are very very
you know stressed and and and felt very
unhappy about the lockdown
and when you think about it it wasn't
because i was locked down differently
than anyone it because it's because
my wishes and hopes from life was was
that i would be able to become what i
used to call a half monk
spend 50 percent of my year in half
in monk like retreats so you lock me
down and i'm like hallelujah the world
has provided
right now now does that mean i'm
disrespectful of the need of people who
are in lockdown and feeling deprived and
feeling alone and
feeling you know scared by covert 19 and
so on and so forth
not at all but but here is here is my
definition
of happiness actually let me start with
my definition of unhappiness because
it's easier to understand
unhappiness is when events minus
expectations is negative
okay it's when the events of life miss
your expectations and hopes and belief
of how beliefs of how life should behave
right now when that happens
your brain your system gives you an
alarm in the form of an emotion
that emotion is simply telling you
something is not exactly how i want it
to be just pay attention please it's
it's worthy
of your attention okay now when you
think about it this way
unhappiness and shame and regret and
fear and worry and all of those negative
emotions
is simply a fire alarm it's a survival
mechanism now if you understand it this
way
you suddenly start to realize oh what is
a fire alarm for
is it there to annoy me is it there for
me to switch it on every day
a few times just to feel the noise or is
it there for me to tell me
that there is something that might be a
threat verify if it's a threat and if it
is take action
okay and and think about it this way
if a fire alarm goes off in this room
right now what
what will i do the natural thing to do
is i will walk outside
i'll verify if there is a fire and i'll
take action if i do that
i don't suffer the noise of the fire
alarm anymore and i've made my world
better
now interestingly that's not what we do
about happiness
you you know your partner tells you
something hurtful on
on friday right so on saturday you wake
up and say he or she doesn't love me
anymore
on sunday you wake up and say it's
because i'm fat on monday you say i
hate dating so i'm never gonna go on
date on a date again on wednesday you
say he or she must be cheating on me
i'll spend the rest of my life alone now
when you really think about that the
event happened on friday
it hurts your feelings that's a fire
alarm that basically says
send them a text and say baby can we
please talk about this because it hurt
me
but instead you choose to to play the
fire alarm again on sunday and monday
and tuesday
that's like the netflix of unhappiness
okay i seriously i mean it's unhappiness
on demand the event happened that is
over
and you choose not to do anything about
it but sit in the fire alarm
now if you ask me is that manageable i
mean
can we actually control that yes of
course
control it like you control the fire
alarm i have a flow chart of three
questions
okay question number one is if my brain
tells me he or she doesn't love me
anymore i'll ask the question is it true
brain
okay is this statement true should i
upset myself for the rest of my life
about it or are you just freaking making
this up
right if it's true if it's not true i'll
drop it if it is true
then question number two what can i do
about it is there something i can do
about it can i talk to them
can i maybe you know send them a text
message can i leave them and look for
someone else whatever
if there is something you can do do it
if there isn't
okay then yeah maybe that's like now the
jedi master mastered level of
of happiness but it's not very difficult
you ask yourself the third question
okay can i accept it and do something
that makes life
better despite its presence okay my
partner seems to be breaking up with me
and there is no way we can fix this i
could sit in a room
hit my head against the wall for 27
years or i can simply say okay that
relationship is over
what can i do now can i get up go to the
gym find another partner
you know is there something i can do to
make life better despite that breakup
and if we think about life that way 99
of the things that make us unhappy in
all honesty
don't deserve the unhappiness they you
know i had a friend of mine walk into my
office once and you know she said uh the
uber driver was super rude
and i was like oh i'm i'm so sorry about
that so she said
okay can we go have coffee and i was
like that's it you're not gonna complain
about the uber driver for uh for half an
hour and she said why
you know it was a seven minute drive it
was super rude should i spend the next
seven hours of my life complaining about
it
and ruin my day seven days seven minutes
done i told you it's off my chest let's
go have coffee
what you say strikes me as being as
simple as it is true
uh mo and simplicity is the hallmark of
truth uh
in my view based on my own experience
how would you relate your understanding
of happiness with a more nuanced more
natural deeper
idea of growth so
i define two things so my equation says
events minus expectations it doesn't say
events minus ambitions
okay and these are two very different
things so so
you know when i started uh i wrote solve
for happy my book it became an
international bestseller and then i went
on tv for interviews
some of them got viral within eight
weeks from release of uh solve for happy
we had 87 million views of which more
than 10 million
had taken action at the time the mission
was 10 million happy
right so we sat back as a group we were
a group of four or five at the time
and we said let's increase the mission
okay
i didn't go from 10 million to 12
million i went from 10 million to a
billion happy
now that is an ambition
don't get me wrong it took jesus 2000
years to reach a billion people i am
nobody i'm never going to reach a
billion people it's as simple as that
but it's a wonderful ambition to have
it's a wonderful directional aspiration
to wake up to every morning
my expectation on the other hand is i am
a normal human
i know a little bit about this topic i
can probably reach out to a few thousand
people a day
and hopefully if i reach out and do this
right i'll make a few hundred people
happy every day and maybe every now and
then
i'll have someone excited enough to
become a champion
and spread the message on their own and
you'll never know
maybe if i as i said as per our mission
if i do this enough
those champions will trigger other
champions and will have a million people
making a billion people happy
now that's an amazing amazing amazing
dream but it's not an expectation
i can't hold myself down to it and say
you gave yourself a target
a billion happy you have 10 years more
to live you know you need to get a 10
million
or 100 million happy every year you're
falling back on your target i can't do
that
okay all i can do is to say woke up
today
have two public talks today and an
interview reached a few hundred people
did a post you know with a proper
content online
that's the best i could do today i wrote
a book i'm editing hopefully
you know on saturday sunday monday great
that's the best i can do
and that's a proper expectation if the
expectation
is met i'm happy if the ambition is
missed
i'm realistic no all of a sudden what
goes through my mind mo
is i think 20 30 years ago a friend of
mine dr jerry jambolsky
said uh he was meeting mother teresa
and she was somewhere in the slums of
india
and she was taking care of a very ill
person
and then somebody came to her said dear
dear uh
mother please be aware there are ten
thousand people waiting in an auditorium
to be uh addressed by you about
um health and all that kind of stuff
really indirectly of course related to
health
and now we we talk in numbers and then
her
answer was that you can see what i'm
doing
[Music]
so that brings to me always reflection
um where am i myself with my
attention am i close to the person that
needs me most
at this time and while being aware that
perhaps
there's somewhere else our people
potentially
can be healed as well but in bigger
numbers and
how do you look at such a choice what
would you do it in such a situation
and i asked the question you may ask
perhaps what
how does it relate to growth for me it
relates to the growth in my
consciousness
that i asked these questions how can i
be more assisted in healing how can i be
a more whole person how can i grow to a
more
more whole person i i uh
i'll answer two i'll answer this on two
levels um
level one is and i say that with a ton
of respect
we humans have somehow forgotten
how flimsy we are okay we've started to
learn to play god
all the time it's as if i am the one
that's going to make a billion people
happy when i when i wrote soul for happy
you know i have that very weird approach
of testing things like i test software
so i i spoke about solve for happy in
stanford university and
in hong kong technical university okay
and at
the end of my talk before the book was
even published
um before my at the end of my talk which
was normally eight hours a full workshop
for the whole day
uh at the end of my talk in hong kong
university a wonderful woman
walked to me and said by the way
you have not chosen this mission and i
said
what you mean and she said you have not
chosen to make
hundreds of millions of people happy at
the time it was 10 million happy
uh she said that mission has chosen you
okay and so i was i was looking at her
and then someone else asked the question
you know how people would gather around
at the end of a speech so i looked at
them and said uh
just give me one minute looked back at
her and she wasn't there
right and in my mind she just hit
a very interesting chord because she
reminded me of what my son used to teach
me so my son
who left our world was really really
really my guru in so many ways and
you know i i'm i was that googly
executive who
always looks at the world as billions of
opportunities and
you know i need to reach a billion more
users you know make a billion more
dollars and so on and so forth
and i had that illusion in my head that
i actually can do that stuff
because i've done it many times you know
i've started businesses i've grown
stuff and so on and he walks into my
room ali
and he says papa there's something i
need you to understand
i think he was 17 at the time and and i
said what have you
and he said you're never going to fix
the world you know that
and i was like what do you mean why are
you bringing that why where is your
spark
ali why don't you have a spark in you
that gets you excited every morning and
he said papa
listen to what i said you're never going
to fix the world
okay there's always going to be someone
suffering there's always going to be
someone in need there's always going to
be someone that's unjustly treated
you're never going to fix the world what
you can do
is fix your little world and if you fix
your little world your little world will
grow
i said oh okay that actually sounds
interesting what does that mean
he said well you're trying to make so
many people
better at work or whatever make yourself
better
okay you're trying to make so many
people happier
make yourself happier if you do it well
enough you'll be able to make me and my
sister and my mother happier
and if you do that well enough you're
going to extend to the rest of the
family
and if you do that well enough you're
going to get to your department than
your company than your country and then
the world will send you people
to make them happier because you got
better at it so instead of trying to
reach a billion people when you're
crappy at what you're doing
just be good at what you are by fixing
your little world and then your little
world will grow
and when you really think about it most
of us
end up changing the world
from the most unexpected place
ever okay so and by the way not about
changing the world changing your life
changing your family changing your
career
all of the things that really mattered
ever mattered in your life
happened so unexpectedly okay most of
them
were not your design most on that most
of them were not even on your plan i
interviewed on slo-mo the most
incredible angel because you said mother
teresa i think the living mother teresa
in our life
is a person called dr edith hager yeah
it is is just
an absolute angel in a human body
93 years of age when i interviewed edis
uh
you know she told me about how she was
taken to auschwitz
when she was 16 years of age okay and
edith
was there and she basically spent her
time
you know she walks into auschwitz and
the general the angel of death
literally sent his sentences her mother
to death
the minute they walk in okay and she
spends the time
in in the concentration camp helping
others survive
right and she says because i helped
others survive
when it was the death march at the end
of the
of of my journey in in that uh you know
story
i would i was so frail
that i was falling to the ground and
then i would see two women
coming from behind me carrying me from
both sides and keeping me going so that
they don't shoot me
right when edith was found eventually
after the war she was
buried under four layers of dead bodies
and her finger
moved and so the soldiers dug her out
and she became she
she stayed with us helped millions of
people
find contentment find happiness find
peace
through that experience do you think
anyone would ever sign up for that
experience to become a teacher nobody
would
the world takes us through what we need
to go through
so that we develop our own self
in a way that allows us to to impact on
the rest of the world
we can't grow the the rest of the world
we can only grow our own selves
okay and if we think about life this way
i'm not god
i'm not aiming to find the billion happy
i am the tool
through which some wisdom from older
people
before me some discoveries from some
scientists whatever
is being channeled to the rest of the
world that's all i do
and if we all start to think about our
lives that way we would be a little less
arrogant if you want in in terms of
understanding if the 10 000 people that
are waiting in the speech
are better for me to focus on or if this
one person
who i might change the life of who might
invent something that saves a billion
people
okay how do how can i tell which one is
right
the one that's right is the one in front
of me okay and if i can
focus myself to say in this moment i'm
gonna do the absolute best i can to have
the best conversation i can have with
you guys okay
and then when when this conversation is
done i'll turn and
focus on my next conversation at eight
pm
okay if i can do that right then every
one of those conversations will be the
best it can be
we just stopped we have to stop thinking
that
those choices are all up to us that
those choices are all
uh delegated to us those choices are
sometimes
the choices of the universe the universe
decides i need you to be here because
there is something you need to do for me
here
because someone else will pick it from
you and then he will do something and
then she will do something
and then the world will change to grow
ourselves into instruments
right not into main actors of the play
um mo a a more sensitive
difficult topic um at the core
of what we call growth in our
civilization today
and that's our economic system you
alluded to it earlier in the interview
capitalism it seems our economic system
is completely focused on growth
investors
invest to allow the development of new
initiatives
because they expect growth we call it
roi return on investment
everything we do is coordinated by an
economic system that is
focused and directed towards growth and
yet
our planet is not growing and the
resources available to us on this planet
if anything they are they are being
depleted we are losing some atmosphere
every year for instance a little bit of
oxygen and noble gases and nitrogen
how are we to
to deal with it because all our of our
efforts the way we organize our
collective effort
is informed by a focus on infinite
growth which is of course
not possible at all to achieve we will
hit a wall at some point
so how are we to organize ourselves to
grow differently
so so there is there is no collective
effort sadly i
i think that's probably the most
misunderstood
uh uh part of what we're go what we're
up ahead uh
uh up up against i think i think the
truth is
um i'm not a policy maker i'm not an
auto maker i'm not
uh um you know i i can't
i can't change the world i'll go back to
that same point
but i can change my world i can actually
make a choice
that says i'm not going to replace my
galaxy
i think i have a note 9 or something
right regardless of how much how many
times
samsung is going to advertise i'm not
going to change my galaxy until it
breaks
or you know something comes up comes out
that has a significant advantage to my
productivity or positivity to the planet
or whatever
until then i'm not just gonna have
another fancy phone
okay i can make a choice that says i
will
uh try to have as much of my speaking
engagements and my meetings as i
absolutely can on zoom even if they
remove us from lockdown
it's all about individual uh uh
impact and i and i you know i i normally
work on several books at the same time
one of the books i'm working on now is
called understanding fate
and when i talk about the idea that the
fate of our planet is in every single
person's hand i also discussed that same
concept in scary smart
you know when i say when i talk about
the changes we need to make
so that artificial intelligence actually
loves us and takes care of us
you may tell yourself oh no no that's
impossible that we need a law or we need
like a president
to tell us to do it no by the way every
little thing that's ever taken one side
of a scale
from the right to the left was done with
the very last gram that you added to the
right
okay and that very last gram is you
that very last you know reduction in co2
you know generation that is destroying
our planet
is the uh uh the thing that you burned
yesterday
right you know that that the very last
uh uh
reduction of single-use plastic that
kills uh
you know it takes a the life of a fish
or a bird today
was that tiny little uh plastic
bottle cap that you threw away
carelessly okay
so the change that is needed is you
the only change that can actually make a
difference is if you stop
i do a very interesting exercise by the
way i'm
very very obsessive about recycling
plastic but
before i do that i decided a few weeks
ago
to keep all of my plastic production or
consumption on my account my my
kitchen's counter top
before i recycle it okay i ran
out of space on day two this is the
truth
and it drove decisions in my life to see
how much i'm doing
i'm generating and so growth in that
state in in that in that
in that concept if you want
is you growing
up to be responsible now that is the
growth we need
okay it is you growing to the point
where you say
i'm in charge i actually can save the
planet
i can actually make the planet happy how
do i do that
i make one tiny little change in my own
life and then through six degrees of
separation see the impact
okay and i don't think people see that i
don't i think
the illusion of governance and the
illusion of presidents that will make
our lives better and the illusion of
responsible
corporations that will you know start to
produce products that make all of our
lives
amazing and responsible for the planet
dream on good luck with that okay
the only thing you can affect today
is one less plastic bottle okay the only
thing you can affect today
is a decision that you're not going to
buy another iphone the only thing that
you
can affect today i drive a 2004 car okay
i make it as efficient as i can i drive
it twice a week
right don't don't tell me i'm gonna buy
electric and i'm going to
just understand i mean of course if if
you don't have a car
buy an electric car if you if you do
have a car
understand that those choices make a
massive difference that the big
difference between
you know saving our planet and not is to
commute
less it's not which car that you use
those cars
for them to be produced are also
polluting our planet for us to get rid
of them
is also polluting our planet and don't
think about all of that think about
yourself
can i grow up and be an adult and take
charge of my life
that's it you've done that you've grown
the results are not up to us mo you're
an
amazing person i hope thank you
not one billion but seven and a half
billion people
listen with their hearts to what you
have to say read what you have to say
this is not my expectation but it is my
ambition
that all seven and a half billion of us
uh give you pay a lot of attention to
what you have to say because
oh my god this is the one way to to get
out of the mess
we are in thank you very much for being
with us today i highly appreciate
it thanks so much and thank you listener
we hope you enjoyed this conversation
growth was the last of the four concepts
that the bionda series has explored
for those of you who can't get enough
don't worry there is a final bonus
episode in store
where fred and i will be reflecting on
each episode
and the series as a whole and seeing if
we can come to any conclusion of our own
thanks for listening or watching and
until next time
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv